Hi, I'm Sadie Sink and I'm here today to share with you what I learned...
...while filming season two of Stranger Things: growing up 80s style.
Can't live without your smartphone?
80s kids did.
Back then, phones had cords, weighed a ton...
...and were typically attached to the kitchen wall.
They were also useful for attempting to call your friends in the upside down.
Barb, is that you?
Creepy but Cuddly Aliens.
Its ears.
Floppy disks.
In the 80s, Cabbage Patch Kids topped every kid's Christmas list.
Parents stampeded through stores.
I mean, they're kinda cute.
Trapper Keeper.
Dot Matrix Paper.
The 80s brought us Nintendo, bringing the arcade to your living room.
You just had to make sure to clean the cartridge before you play.
Blue Eyeshadow.
Shoulder Pads.
I feel powerful.
These little babies divided friends into two groups:...
...those who could solve it,...
...and those who peeled off the stickers to make it look like they could solve it.
Home Workout Videos.
In the 80s, the best way to romance a girl was to stand underneath her window,...
...blaring a slow jam out of your boom box.